china's biggest city shanghai has been
at a standstill for more than six weeks
but the strict pandemic lockdown may be
finally coming to an end for its 25
million people
starting from monday the commercial
center is gradually easing covert 19
restrictions aimed at resuming normal
life from the beginning of june the
mayor's office says infections which
began surging at the end of march are
now under control
yesterday the number of newly discovered
coveted 19 patients dropped below 1000
for the first time and there have been
no positive case reports at the
community level for two consecutive days
the epidemic situation in shanghai has
been effectively controlled
restrictions will be lifted in three
phases starting with the reopening of
some supermarkets pharmacies and
hairdressers
some restaurants will be allowed to
offer takeout but most restrictions on
people's movement will remain until next
week
china is fighting its worst outbreak
since the beginning of the pandemic
coronavirus restrictions have been
imposed in dozens of regions nationwide
including the capital
meanwhile in beijing authorities are
continuing to ask residents to mass test
every second day i'm just lining up now
for my 10th covert test in recent weeks
people living in most beijing districts
have been asked to work from home
china's leaders refuse to co-exist with
the virus and the economy is paying the
price
in april industrial output retail
spending and urban employment all fell
to their lowest levels in two years
home sales are down more than 30 since
last year
china's central bank has cut interest
rates for first-time buyers to help ease
the property slump
shanghai's leaders say it will take time
for everyone to completely resume normal
life
they're desperate to avoid a rebound in
infections as restrictions ease and
millions of residents in some areas
remain confined to their homes
katrina u al jazeera beijing